everyone this is kevin from the chess
website calm today we are in round seven
of the 2016 Tata Steel tournament great
tournament so far in round seven our two
competitors to Dutchman a whites gonna
be played by Luc van Whaley we looked at
his game in round 5 verse magnus carlsen
had an opportunity to actually win
against the champion playing the white
pieces against Magnus Carlsen but made a
fiddle err at the end and end up losing
that game so he's gonna try to redeem
himself playing the white pieces against
a nitch giri another Dutchman the
youngest player in the top 30 in the
world not only that at 21 years old but
he's number 3 in the world so extremely
talented player one of those young
bright prodigies that looks to kind of
potentially take over take Magnus
Carlsen in the future so we have a
exciting game on our hands we'll go
ahead and get started
with Knight to f3 pawn d5 pawn d4 pawn
up here to c4 and then pawn to c6 so
getting into one of the slob variations
after pawn here to e3 Geary has two
options you can play the semi slob with
pawn here to e6 or it could just
continue with the normal slob and that's
way does he plays Bishop out here to g4
and it's kind of a depending on how you
want to play you know pawn here to e6
is a lot more defensive early on you
block off your LightSquared Bishop
you're trying to play defense for the
early part of the game and then look for
a counter-attack but Bishop here to g4
allows you to play a little bit more
aggressive get your LightSquared Bishop
out then you can play pawn to e6 but you
don't really care because your
light-square bishop is already developed
sometimes it can be very difficult for
the LightSquared bishop to really get
involved for black at all depending on
the opening so nice liberation just play
that the normal Slav pawn here to h3
kicking the bishop back Knight here to
see three and then pawn here to e6 now a
white plays pawn here to g4 which is
very very aggressive you can kind of see
he's not gonna be cancelling on the
Queen side because he's kind of exposed
here with with the Queens gambit but you
you're gonna see bishop here - e -
stopping the pin of the bishop on the
night down here - the Queen so bish P R
- E - makes a lot of sense getting ready
to castle on the kingside you could also
just play Queen here - see - all these
are very very common besides for the
more aggressive pawn here - g4 and now
Bishop back here to g6 now why continues
with Knight here to e5 Knight here to d7
and then pawn up here to h4 I think if
you are gonna bring your knight up here
to e5 you should just go ahead and take
this bishop here on g6 allow him to kind
of mess up his King side a little bit
and you now have a bishop pair and he
does not but decides to go ahead and
play pawn up here to h4 starting to
attack a little bit more on at a king
side pawn takes here on c4 and now
Knight over here recapturing on c4 it
and another mini reason I don't like
just the knight recapturing over here is
he really wants his material over here
on the King side that's where his
majority of attack is going to be is
he's pushing forward paneer g4 pawn up
here to h4 and now he kind of has to re
maneuver all of his knights back over
here to the King side he could have
easily just taken away some of the
material that block had and then pushed
forward a little bit more pawn here to
h5 normally when you see paneer to h4
from your opponent's if you decide to go
ahead and stop that attack paneer at age
six is reasonable I just recommend
always just pushing forward with pawn
here - h5
so just keep that Mize you're always
evaluating how you should play if your
opponent's pushing forward here
pioneered HHH for usually just make
sense to play pawn here to h5 stopping
that attack you don't want him all up in
your business pushing forward paneer to
h5 even further beyond that primary to
g5 forcing the Knights move so Knight
here to d5 nice little outpost in the
center of the board [ __ ] period - g2
trying to control the light square
bishop in the center also attacking the
knight here on a g5 or d5 so that comes
back here to b6 pawn up here to b3
defending both the night here
ceefor but also the square here on a
four bishop down here to be four and
this is kind of a nuisance just pinning
down this knight right here why can
always castle if he wants to it seems
pretty dangerous because he has no pawns
kind of in front of his king is he's
kind of pushed forward so very very
risky but he can't move his knight now
this bishops we're gonna be tough to be
you know replaced he can always just
take right here why it's almost forced
to bring his bishop here to d2 who can
also bring his queen but then that's
kind of tied down so you know he be
doing a nice job of putting pressure on
his opponents upon here to e5 trying to
break up the center of the board anytime
you can put pressure on your opponent so
his double bishop pears doing a good job
of hitting all sides all different
angles then just start to kind of
explode in the center of the board that
that's definitely a good strategy a pot
up here to a three and now we start to
see an exchange on board Knight to c4
and then after the pawn takes in the
[ __ ] is gonna come back here still
pinning down that night and white says
hey I'm gonna go ahead and castle on the
Kings side and Anish does the same thing
casting on the Kings side so White's
being super aggressive black although he
doesn't have his aged pawn he saw has a
pretty safe King side structure over
here while white does not and so you
know black is really gonna be looking to
open up the center of the board
his aggressive double bishops are going
to really start to attack over here on
the King side I really try to punish
white for having this exposed King side
over here Luke now pushes forward with
c5 so he is doing a good job of gaining
space he's trying to cramp down the
position of black as much as possible it
is fairly easy for black to still keep
the game open but for right now white is
really pushing forward with this pawns
really trying to open up the game as
much as possible Luke over here to e8
just putting more pressure on the center
of the board you always want your rooks
to control the center of the board if
possible following behind the pawns is
always recommended and we're compared to
eats who really wants to just play rook
here to be won but there's this subtle
little bishop here on
six which kind of a nuisance threatening
that score down here on b1 so he's gonna
kind of maneuver just using an extra
move to bring his work over here to a B
- Queen here - c7 adding another layer
protection on the pawn here on e5 and
now rook here - B - threatening this
pawn here on b7 if this Queen were to
move but now the potters gonna come here
to a b6 and we see an exchange on board
and now pawn up here to d5 and black
says okay I'm gonna allow you to push
forward and I'm gonna play a pawn here
to e4 and pawn d4 is a really nice
square anytime you can get your your
pawns push past kind of the halfway
point and you can still hold on to
pressure here it says a few things one
that allows yourself to set up for some
really nice outpost if you could ever
get is not here - d3 or f3 this is
really nice but it also kind of
separates your opponent's pieces so this
lights were a bishop it's not gonna be
getting involved into the action too
much because it's kind of blocked off
and so it separates both of these pieces
over here and black can just continue to
just improve its position start to put
pressure on his opponent so after pawn
to c6 we see the queen recapture not up
here to b5 now Knight here to e5 both
sides trying to get a better night
position Bishop over here taking on a5
and then the rooks going to recapture a
little bit more aggressive for the rook
it wouldn't be the worst thing in the
move for the pond to take here on a5 but
wants to kind of increase his his
advantage with more pressure so we're
taking her on a5 attacking this knight
forcing the knight to kind of move so
the knight comes back here to d4 nice
little outpost for this Knights Queen
here - d6
now Knight here to e2 it he plays this
Knight to e2 because he recognizes the
next move is going to be Knight to d3
and this is a brutal outpost for this
Knight really controlling a lot of the
backline for whites and so white knows
that he is really gonna have to play
this Knight to f4 to kind of stop this
this Knight right here it's the only
real good way that he has to maneuver
this he can't really move his Bishop you
know three or four times
to take this piece right here and so
that's kind of why you saw that
maneuvering here to e2 and now up here
to f4 now neech plays the rook taking
down here on a3 so gobbling up some
material broke up here to b5 Queen here
to c6 Queen over here to b1 starting to
put more pressure on the pawn on d6 now
the knight says okay I'm gonna go ahead
and take here on f4 the outpost is
definitely not as strong as he has a
knight right here they can always take
it if he wants to
so decides it's actually better to go
ahead in exchange give his opponent's a
double pawn here on the F Iowa and then
kind of open up the door for this pawn
on e4 to push forward if he can Queen
back here to a d7 getting ready to come
down here to the outpost on g4 if
allowed to rook takes here on b6 and now
the Queen comes down here to do 4 and
you can look at and say okay both sides
are fairly equal in material but really
black is is kind of destroying this just
because he has much more active pieces
and these pawns right here they have a
hard time really defending because
they're pushed so forward this Bishop
can't really move because it's kind of
the only protection that this King has
and so black has a lot more active
pieces in the game
than white white really doesn't have a
strong attack on the board this bishops
is still doing a nice job and this rook
here on e8 both protecting a pawn here
on e4 rook up here to b8 just trying to
get some material to board that's fine
rook takes the Queen takes and now the
Kings h7 since it was in check now the
Queen down here to e5 and then rook over
here to f3 so both sides have four pawns
but black is fairly easily gonna be able
to just gobble up some of this material
because all white has is kind of this
Queen right here to hold on to it his
rooks not gonna ever get involved into
the game and his Bishop has we talked
about really can't move at all so the
pawns gonna come up here to f5 the
ship's going to take we're kitty one
trying to do something rook here to f4
adding another layer protection on at
this pawn has
this Bishop rook and Queen all
protecting that we're gonna be 283 now
doing a ton Bishop back here to g6 still
protecting that pawn queen here to d6 so
removing an attacker on the pawn here on
e4 but then blacks just continuing to
just gobble up pieces right here so
Queen takes here on h4 rook swings over
here to g3 work over here Queen to e5
and then hey there's an exchange on
board the rooks come off the board now
Queen here to g4 the King comes up here
and now the Bishop to f5 Queen come here
to a 7 e7 King here to g6 to protect the
square here on f7 now Queen here to e5
but the Queen as we said it's just kind
of hanging out it's not doing anything
it's not in tandem with this Bishop at
all all of a sudden the Queen takes here
on g5 and Luke lin dawei Lee is forced
to resign just down too much material he
is you know three pawns towards the in
game is just too much to overcome so in
this particular case and these Giri wins
the game so he's kind of heading pulled
himself he's in the top three of the
tournament behind Magnus Carlsen Fabiana
caruana who are tied for first
he's a point off of them but a really
strong game he started out in the
tournament losing and then has tied a
few and then is won a couple as well so
he's brought himself back into
contention so really excited to see him
playing well you know Luke fin Whaley me
a hometown hero played in this
tournament for so many years like 25
times in the past 26 years but for some
reason past two times just has not
worked out against some of these top
players in the world even playing as the
white pieces so he'll look to continue
to turn things around in the later half
of this tournament but from here on
exciting we're kind of halfway through
the tournament so hope you guys have
enjoyed and I'll see you guys in the
next round thanks for watching